une fois que tu partes peu plus jamais
revenir en arrière et si tu fais une
erreur crème
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya quelques jours j'ai rencontré
l'explorateur originaire d'afrique du
sud michael alors mike horn en quelques
chiffres c'est 27 pour du droit lyrics à
trois fois le tour du monde à pied il a
donc gravi les plus hauts sommets
descendu à la nage en hydrospeed deux
clubs du monde l'amazone de sa source
jusqu'à l'océan est aujourd'hui au delà
de ça c'est vraiment youtuber bonjour
tout le monde ce n'était pas le plus
impressionnant mais ça reste plutôt
sympa lors de ses nombreuses expéditions
l'explorateur a pris beaucoup de risques
mais l'expédition qui a été la plus
difficile celle en fait qui a failli lui
coûter la vie ça a été celle de 2006 à
la fin du mois d'août en 2019 mike horn
arrive en alaska pour la dernière étape
de son expédition paul tout paul est en
grosse un voyage qu'il fait depuis trois
ans dont l'objectif est de faire le tour
du monde sans moyens motorisés et le
tout en passant par les deux pôles là
c'est donc la toute dernière étape de
son voyage de trois ans et son objectif
c'est donc d'atteindre la banquise pour
rejoindre le pôle nord à skis puis de
continuer sa route pendant encore
environ 1000 km à travers l'arctique
jusqu'aux walbach d' un archipel
norvégien situé entre le groenland et le
spitzberg
le truc c'est que malheureusement cette
expédition ne se déroule pas du tout
comme prévu et pourtant l'article c'est
pas un territoire inconnu pour mike horn
puisque en 2006 treize ans plus tôt avec
son coéquipier norvégien borghi ausland
ils avaient été les premiers à atteindre
le pôle nord en hiver le pouls en pleine
nuit polaire est étroite et aurore
martin 6
explosé
[Applaudissements]
en 2006 on en arrive en pole on était au
bout de nuit on a vraiment pensé que
c'était impossible de traverser des
ponots lors de cette première expédition
en 2006 la traversée de l'arctique sans
assistance et sans ravitaillement leur
semble alors un faisable d'ailleurs
après avoir atteint le pôle nord micky
borghi ont été récupérés en hélicoptère
et donc ils n'ont pas continué leur
route de l'autre côté du pôle et puis
entre 2006 et 2010 9 il y avait 15 ans
qui a passé et puis tout d'un coup on a
oublié
qu'on a dit c'est impossible
alors en 2010 9 13 ans après il décide
d'y retourner mais cette fois ci le défi
est plus grand puisque non seulement il
faut atteindre le pôle nord et au delà
de ça il faut aussi traversé l'arctique
et ce dans un contexte particulier
puisque on est au début de l'hiver fin
août mike et borghi arrive donc en
alaska and home et c'est tout simplement
le dernier contact pour o2 avec la
civilisation avant la traversée et la
banquise c'est important de de commencer
un homme tout simplement parce que c'est
là où tu pas encore prendre décision de
s'engager ou de dire non stop une fois
que tu partes peu plus jamais revenir en
arrière et si tu fais une erreur tu
crées sur dire que l'engagement est à
100% tuez pas là pour jouer c'est plus
un jeu c'est pas juste quelque chose que
tu veux faire parce que tu veux dire que
je suis le premier round 4 merci les
polypes au nord tu dois vraiment croire
en toi même quand on arrive à nous mêmes
on évoque citée parce que c'est une
expédition qu'on a planifié des pays
deux ans le 2 septembre 2019 mike
embarque donc abords du pont gaïa son
voilier avec son coéquipier borghi le
tout donc en direction de la banquise
mais le pont gaïa n'est pas un brise
glace et donc il ne peut pas s'engager
sur des voies en fait où la glace serait
épaisse pour pouvoir donc traversé ils
vont utiliser des cartes satellites pour
identifier et suivre les routes où la
glace est plus fine et donc où le
voilier peut passer on a assez de
connaissances et de savoir-faire
d'arriver là où tu vas arriver et puis
ça veut dire qu'un bateau un peu de
connaissances epn équipage un équipage
qui croit en toi parce qu'il n'ya pas
beaucoup d'équipiers qui travaille sur
les bateaux qui peut résister quand il
commence d'affaires - cinq mois dix
mouillé vivent la neige des tombes est
énorme ou tu dors très peu se dire qu'il
faut une résistance pendant trois
semaines le voilier de mike horn donc
traverser le détroit de béring attendre
l'océan arctique et se rapprocher
progressivement de la banquise mike et
borg il constate alors me première
anomalie pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de notre planète il ya un
bateau à voile
qui est pas brise glace qui arrive à 85
degrés nord
avant il y avait que la glace il faut un
brise-glace nucléaire pour arriver là le
bateau va les déposer à une latitude de
85 degrés nord est dit comme ça c'est
peut être un détail pour vous mais pour
eux ça veut dire où beaucoup en fait
jamais jusqu'ici un voilier qui donc n'a
pas de brise-glaces n'avait pu se
rapprocher autant du pôle nord la raison
est bien c'est le dérèglement climatique
qui provoque la fonte des glaces et qui
permet au pont gaïa d'avancer aussi loin
mike borghi ou emporter 2 traîneau
chacun détenant environ 75 jours de
nourriture pour un total de 180 kg par
personne à ce moment là il espère encore
terminée l'expédition en 60 jours
[Applaudissements]
les deux explorateurs sont alors très
vite confronté à des difficultés et les
premiers jours sur la glace sont loin
très loin d'être facile dès le troisième
jour sur la banquise micky et borghi ont
un peu l'impression marcher sur un tapis
roulant ont commencé à marcher mais si
vivons souffle dans un mauvais sens on
marche mais on reste sur place c'est à
dire que la glace peut dériver ah oui
kilomètres à l'heure by km à l'heure et
moi avec un traîneau chargé avec la
nourriture du füle l'attend est en fait
du matériel de survie je dois marcher
plus vite que la dérive la glace et
c'est quasiment impossible
en fait à cause du dérèglement
climatique
la glace est beaucoup plus fine est
beaucoup plus fragile elle se fracturent
donc et dérives plus rapidement vers le
sud et ce alors qu'il se dirige à ce
moment là vers le nord mike et borghi
marche quotidiennement six à neuf heures
par jour mais il ne parcourt pourtant
que 45 km les cinq premiers jours c'est
très peu et cette dérive de la glace est
loin d'être le seul obstacle sur leur
parcours en 2006 on n'a pas pris un
bateau gonflable avec nous on a pris en
combinaison étanche comme et et par
dessus tout nos vêtements pour que quand
la glace casse et puis il ya cette
brèche d'eau qu'ils ouvrent on pouvait
sauter dans l'eau est passée à la marche
à saint-élie méthodes qu'on a utilisées
en 2006 pour aller aux pauvres le
problème c'est que là aussi la situation
a évolué en 2006 les trous dans la
banquise ne faisait que quelques
dizaines de mètres mais en 2019 et bien
c'est très différent à cause toujours du
dérèglement climatique
ces trous font parfois quelques
centaines de mètres autrement dit il est
devenu trop dangereux de les traverser à
la nage et ce malgré leur combinaison
étanche comme tu vois à moi 40 quand il
fait moins 40 à l'extérieur tu vois dont
l'eau et l'eau fais moi 2
la première sensation que
que tu peux avoir quand on rentre dans
l'eau qu'à moi ou il fait chaud mais fur
et à mesure que tu nages l'air retour de
tes vêtements
parce que tu es dans l'eau est compressé
et l'air sort ça veut dire que tu es
plus tu n'as plus l'air chaud autour des
vêtements et tu commences d'avoir froid
tu peux rester dans l'eau comme ça pour
dix minutes 10 12 minutes après tu va
choper la dépouille terme et la grèce et
donc si fragile voire complètement
inexistante par endroits que mikey
borghi ne peuvent plus progresser
uniquement avec leurs skis ils doivent
donc utiliser des bateaux gonflables
pour traverser ces étendues
le 15 octobre le soleil se couche autour
du pôle pour une période assez longue
puisque c'est une période de six mois ce
que l'on appelle la nuit polaire mike et
borghi le savent chaque jour ils auront
désormais de moins en moins de lumière
ils doivent donc utiliser des lampes
frontales pour s'éclairer or progresser
dans l'obscurité la plus totale de zinc
et même de plus en plus compliqué
surtout lorsqu'il faut affranchir des
zones de compression inattendue des
zones de compression c'est quand la
glace dérivent on dise qu'il ya une
masse de glace qui arrive dépit canada
et puis elle masque glace qui arrive
débit la russie et ses deux masses de
glace devient en collusion une avec
l'autre et la glace casse donc lorsque
la glace se font elles forment des murs
à franchir ça veut dire que des zones de
compression maintenant devient de plus
en plus grande et des traversées cette
zone de compression avec la luge qui
pèse 160 kg et en ski pendant la nuit
c'est ça a compliqué les choses un 2019
le 19 octobre micky borghi se
rapprochent ils ne sont plus qu'à 200 km
du pôle nord et il rencontre pourtant
encore de la glace brisée en fait pour
faire très simple ils ne reconnaissent
plus rien de la banquise qu'ils avaient
rencontrés il y à 13 ans selon un récent
rapport de l'amap la région qui entoure
le pôle nord se réjouit en fait trois
fois plus vite que le reste de la
planète conséquence l'épaisseur de la
banquise a quasiment été divisé par deux
depuis 2000 et là où elle faisait à 3 m
elle ne fait en 2019
plus qu'un mètre cinquante voire
seulement quelques centimètres par an
mike et borghi marche donc sept à huit
heures par jour sur une glace qui peut
se briser à tout moment en dessous d'eux
sous la glace 3000 mètres d'eau à -2
degrés la concentration et donc extrême
firme mesure que l'on avance vers
l'épaule et comment cette affaire de
plus en plus froid de plus c'est plus un
nuit on devient fatigué l'état d'esprit
des deux explorateurs change alors au
lieu de profiter des paysages il ne se
préoccupe plus que des dangers
potentiels
les yeux rivés sur les menaces dès qu'on
sort de cette zone de confort ou tout en
cours tu veux plus une voiture tu veux
qu lune mais ils ont quand même pas
envie de marcher et tu penses qu'à à
rester vivant et d'avancer tu pars plus
toutes les 90 minutes mike et borghi
prennent donc une pause mais une pause
pendant laquelle ils ne se parlent pas
afin de conserver leur énergie en
arrivant du prédit paul on a marché on
jours pour faire en degrés ça veut dire
qu'en de graisse et 60000 et 60000
normalement on fait 1 4 jours c'est à
dire que fut en mesure qu'on avance et
on mettait l'attend à la fin de la
journée et puis ont reculé dany
jusqu'à où on a commencé du jour d'arrêt
et puis on a fait pendant 11 jours dix
allers-retours et ça on voit très
rarement on a vu très rarement 2006 le
29 octobre 35 jours après avoir été
déposée sur la banquise micky borghi
parviennent enfin à atteindre le pôle
nord
le truc c'est que ils ont encore 1000 km
à parcourir jusqu'à l'archipel norvégien
du svalbard
c'est là-bas que le voilier de mike horn
le pont gaïa doit les récupérer mike et
borghi compte alors sur le
refroidissement des températures pour
que la glace s'épaississent et donc ils
espèrent que la seconde moitié du trajet
sera plus simple malheureusement rien ne
se déroule comme prévu une météo
défavorable
une tempête au delà de ça le stock de
nourriture qui s'épuise à cause du
retard et pour ne rien arranger quelques
erreurs d'inattention qui met les deux
explorateurs en très grave danger le 22
novembre le traîneau de borghi reste
coincé dans la glace et en tentant de le
dégager avec la pression exercée et bien
la glace va tout simplement cédé sous
son poids une situation comme ça tu
tu dois essayer tout de suite dans les
bêtas luge dans les délices qui prépare
et la corde lancer la corde vers
quelqu'un qui a tombé dans l'eau pour
que tu es chaud que la corde
et que tu peux le tirant d'eau mais si
tu peux peuvent pas faire ça
tu peux pas juste approcher parce
qu'elle la glace va casser et après
deux bandeaux c'est pas c'est pas les
bières après une grosse frayeur borghi
parvient à s'extraire de l'eau
l'humidité n'a heureusement pas
traverser ces vêtements et il va se
rouler directement dans la neige alors
pourquoi se rouler dans la neige c'est
ce que l'on appelle le freeze rising
c'est une méthode de séchage par le gel
l'humidité et elle est absorbée et gelé
par la neige et la neige gelée peut
ensuite être enlevé des vêtements trois
jours plus tard c'est au tour de la
météo de jouer contre eux les deux
explorateurs sont en fait bloqué par une
tempête qui les contraint de s'arrêter
et de se réfugier dans leur tente ils
prennent donc encore du retard sur le
plan initial
mike et borghi non alors qu'une semaine
de nourriture en stock sept jours donc
pour parcourir 150 km c'est donc à ce
moment là une véritable course contre la
montre qui débute
[Applaudissements]
c'est jamais fini jusqu'à c'est fini
quand on calcule la distance qu on a
marché puis ce qu'on a fait et puis on
voit qu'on a plus assez de nourriture
dans la luge on sait qu'on doit faire
quelque chose qui sont l'ordinaire pour
finir l'expédition à ce moment-là may
cry borghi décidé d'intensifier le
rythme et malgré l'épuisement ils
marchent désormais six heures
supplémentaires chaque jour parce que
c'est une semaine
c'est quand c'est fini c'est fini pour
nous mais maintenant on peut faire
encore une différence en ajoutant 7 6
heures qu'à chaque quatrième jour ont
gagné en jours de nourriture et on ne
dormait pas on n'arrivait pas en
parallèle les deux explorateurs photo
c'est un choix plutôt contre intuitif il
décide de manger encore plus qu'avant
normalement comme tu es un peu dans la
mer comme ça je pense à ok je dois
manger la moitié de la ration mais à ce
moment là tu vas devenir faible tu es
déjà faible il fait trop froid il fait
nuit tu es fatigué et c'est là où j'ai
di borgo on doit vraiment j'ai une
double ration pour corps maintenant par
voir l'énergie d'avancer en novembre
malgré les efforts des deux explorateurs
l'entourage de mike horn envisage quand
même d'aller des sourires en hélicoptère
l'hélico oui c'est une option mais nos
pas pas de ma tête peut-être dans la
tête de mes filles qui voulaient garder
leur papa vivante mais
sur la glace pour moi c'était c'était
vraiment la seule solution c'était à
pied jusqu'à la fin et si j'arrive pas à
la fin je ne mérite pas
mais début décembre après 81 jours sur
la glace le traîneau de borghi se
cassent les deux explorateurs ont alors
aucun autre choix que de s'arrêter pour
essayer de le réparer ce qui est assez
inquiétant pour deux raisons déjà le peu
de nourriture qu'il le reste et au delà
de ça tout le chemin qu'il leur reste à
parcourir amaigri mike et borghi ont
chacun perdu entre 10 et 15 kg et
fatigués ils comprennent qu'ils ne
parviendront pas à atteindre le pont
gaïa à ce moment là il décide donc de
rentrer en contact avec un bateau
norvégien le lancer est ce bateau le
lancer est prêt à les récupérer si les
prises dans la glace il va résister un
tout petit peu plus longtemps je savais
sur pandaria c'était ma famille mes amis
les gens qui vont tout faire pour venir
me sauver je voulais pas mettre leur vie
en péril pour vous ma vie l'équipage du
lancer et les deux explorateurs se donne
donc rendez-vous à une latitude de 80 2
degrés nord pour le rejoindre micky
borghi doive encore parcourir keim 90 km
en trois jours et lors des derniers
kilomètres une erreur d'inattention met
en péril la vie de mike on a deux jours
à faire jusqu'au bateau on sait qu'on
peut rester en jour en jour et demi sans
nourriture on a une chance d'arriver
vivent en europe au nord il n'ya pas de
lumière il ya des étoiles il ya la lune
mais il n'y a pas la lumière
artificielle et de la loi 2
et on 26 kg mais je voyais la lumière du
bateau je marche devant de la direction
de la lumière et puis ils y vont souffle
la neige est déposé sur l'eau et je
voyais pas la différence
entre la neige posé sur la glace et la
neige posé sur l'eau
et tout d'un coup c'est comme quelqu'un
tire un tapis et t'as plus rien sur tes
pieds et pour agace et tu tombes dans
l'eau à cause des skis mike est tiré au
fond de l'eau il tente par tous les
moyens de garder la tête à la surface et
à l'extérieur son coéquipier borghi
accourent pour l'aider et je l'écris
qu'il doit arrêter parce que si moi j'ai
tombé dedans lui aussi va tomber dedans
et puis de mort ça vaut pas la peine
c'est moi qui a fait l'erreur c'est moi
qui doit payer on essaye toujours de
faire quelque chose qui peut faire un
petit différence mais dans la situation
où je me trouvais semeta tête dans l'eau
sortait ce qui est tu peux rester vivant
si tu fais pas ça tu meurs comme des
gens me demandent si j'ai peur mais
c'est sûr que j'ai peur mes mains la
peur c'est ma maison la peur c'est là où
j'habite la peur c'est ça me donne cette
sensation d'être vivant en se mettant en
arrière mike parvient finalement à se
dégager et à sortir de l'eau son état
est critique mais il sait qu'il a encore
une chance d'atteindre le bateau au
moment où ils repartent nouveaux
problèmes de l'autre côté le lancer est
pris dans la glace et ne peut plus
continuer à avancer vers mike et borghi
deux explorateurs norvégiens de
l'équipage alexander gamme et bing
frottements quitte alors le bateau en
ski de randonnée est avec des réserves
de nourriture pour aller laisse courir
il le 6 décembre les quatre explorateurs
se rejoignent enfin
et c'est justement là où pour la
première fois
pour cette expédition pendant cette
exposition envoyé deux autres êtres
humains après trois mois sur la glace
on a vécu seul au milieu de ces nuits
noires où il ya personne est là en
voyant les gens on sait qu'on a une
chance
d'arriver
24 heures plus tard les quatre
explorateurs regagne enfin le long c'est
à ce moment précis il ne restait à micky
borghi qu'une seule rations de
nourriture selon vous l'imaginez un
immense soulagement j'ai été
exactement où je voulais joue lettre à
ce moment là je traverse eléonore on a
fait quelque chose on aucune être humain
à faire sur notre planète il y avait
plus de gens qui a marché sur la lune
qui a traversé les fourneaux
[Applaudissements]
cette expédition en arctique a été
l'expédition la plus difficile de la
carrière de mike horn et les difficultés
d'ailleurs qu'il a rencontrés sont le
reflet véritablement du dérèglement
climatique la fonte de la banquise
arctique a d'ailleurs atteint un record
absolu
la première semaine de septembre 2020
chaque jour durant cette période ses
quatre vingt mille kilomètres carrés de
glace soit deux fois la superficie du
danemark qui ont fondu les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui qui débute dans
l'exploration pour eux c'est presque
trop tard maintenant d'avoir 10 15 ans
d'expérience
pour essayer de traverser l'antarctique
dans dix quinze ans je pense qu'on peut
plus de fer et la banquise ne se réduit
pas seulement en superficie mais elle
est aussi devenue plus jeune et plus
mince au cours des dernières années je
pense que l'homme il a accéléré
ce qui se passe sur notre planète on
brûle les sens on réchauffe on coupe les
jambes ont bondi poisson on lance les
plastiques dans la mer je traverse
héliport l'epo sur la planète est petit
il est pas énorme ça veut dire quand on
doit prendre soin de notre petit planète
parce que la vie c'est pas seulement à
paris au autour de chez nous la vie
c'est partout autour de notre planète
autre illustration du dérèglement
climatique
micky borghi n'ont rencontré aucun ours
polaires lors de leur expédition en 2006
chaque 2e 3e jour on voyait des ours
polaires il y avait même un ours polaire
qui était assise sur la tente sur moi en
intérieur la tante 2019
en
90 jours on n'a pas vu un seul ours
polaires on a vu deux ou trois fois les
traces d'ours polaires médias plus
d'ours polaires ils sont où les phoques
indispensable à l'alimentation des ours
polaires ne peuvent plus se poser sur la
glace car celles ci on vient de le dire
est trop fragile
conséquence les restes dans l'eau et les
ours polaires ne peuvent plus les
chasser j'ai toujours été très sensible
au sujet de l'écologie tout simplement
parce que en fait ma vie et à
l'extérieur et physiquement tu vois des
changements beaucoup plus vite que
quelqu'un qui va pas s'ils ont des
renvois moi je pense que la plus grande
source d'énergie qui ait jamais utilisée
c'est déjà y sont mieux formés que moi
la chance tu le provoque
et je savais très bien en quittant mon
bateau pour traverser l'ipo nord si je
ne mets pas tout
je veux pas avoir la chance il ya deux
jours dans la vie tu peux choisir de
marcher au bord de la falaise
où tu peux choisir de marcher loi de la
falaise moi j'ai décidé que je veux
vivre sur la falaise parce que j'ai une
vue extraordinaire je veux pas vivre
loin de la falaise où je vois en riant
toute ma vie où je fais rien toute ma
vie j'ai décidé de profiter de chaque
instant de ma vie est-ce que j'ai peur
de mourir non
j'ai peur plutôt pas de vie
en tout cas j'espère que cette rencontre
avec mike horn vous aura plu c'est le
cas sachez que vous pouvez retrouver
d'autres rencontres et interviews
reportages et c'est sur cette nouvelle
chaîne youtube donc n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner si jamais ce n'est pas encore le
cas pour nous soutenir et ne pas louper
les vidéos suivantes un grand merci donc
à mike horn pour ce temps je vous mets
libyen de sa chaîne youtube en
descriptions verser aussi enfin antoine
de la chaîne en taboulé science qui nous
a aidé pour le tournage en suisse je
crois que je te dis prenez soin de vous
et on se dit à très vite pour une
nouvelle vidéo